[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the ramsey headquarters in
nashville tennessee this is the ramsay
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money
i'm john delony joined here by my good
friend rachel cruz the smartest person
on radio and that was rachel not me and
we're here to take your calls about
that's the title about money life
whatever is going on in your life we
have a packed house out there it's good
to see everybody down here visiting us
in nashville it's good to see you and
give us a buzz the call is free
and the advice is worth about that much
too triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go out to alexis in phoenix what's up
alexis
yeah hi thank you for taking my call of
course
my question is with regards to the
emergency fund from step three
i have several different savings
accounts including some accounts that
are more like sinking funds
is that emergency fund the sum total of
what's in all of the accounts or only
within a dedicated emergency fund
account
uh i would say what's dedicated in the
emergency fund account because your
syncing funds are to be used eventually
for something right you're saving up for
a vacation or you're saving up for a car
well
one of them would be for a new car but
like one of them is is what i generally
call my bill account and it includes
things like
car maintenance and house maintenance
and things so a lot of things that
people would normally call emergencies
like new tires or something um all of
that would come out of that fund at
start point when needed
yes okay um so i'll tell you what
winston and i do
so we have an emergency fund and it's
six i actually made us put like eight to
nine months
just in case i'm like let's just have a
little bit of a buffer all the way so we
have we have that money state and it is
in a completely different account it is
like it's just we never touch it it's
just over there and then we have a money
market account so after we do all of our
investing and we do our giving and our
spending if we have some money left over
then we put that amount of money into a
different account
and that's what we really use that
account for things that come up that are
quote-unquote emergencies right the um
something happened to my car like two
weeks ago so we we had to
uh use some of that money and we didn't
touch the emergency fund that was over
there we used that other account that we
kind of just had money in
for those kind of expenses does that
make sense
yes okay so i would if i were you alexis
just to keep it clean and neat i would
have just a separate account for your
emergency fund and it's over there and
you literally don't touch it
ever
unless you absolutely have to and that's
what it's there for it's the ultimate
safety net okay okay alexis can i lean
into something while i got you yes
are you is it okay is it okay if i pry a
little bit
sure okay what he's good at oh prepare
your prepare your heart alexis
so
i i consider this a
um a national challenge that we're
experiencing okay
and it is
complexity
as an antidote to anxiety
okay here's what i mean by that
we're an anxious group of people in this
country we have a lot going on and our
bodies are trying to get our attention
that things aren't okay that we're not
living in sustainable ways one of the
ways we combat anxiety is by just doing
nothing okay
but one of the ways high performing
people which you clearly are i could
tell in the first 30 seconds of your
question
is more data
as a way to quell anxiety i'm gonna have
another cup of coffee i'm gonna go ask
my friend this and i've gotten four
opinions i'm gonna go ahead and get one
more i'm gonna go talk to this guy i'm
gonna read this book is that you
um yes it is yes except for often
sharing with with
close family and for like asking
opinions of other people because i don't
necessarily think they handle their
money properly yes okay good so you're
judgmental too i love it you and i are
very similar
um another way we we burn off this
anxious energy
is through complexity
i've got 18 different accounts i got
four at this bank i got three at this
bank i got a spreadsheet but then i've
got a second spreadsheet that helps me
with it see where i'm going yes
what i would suggest is the way rachel
laid it out is simplicity and there's
peace in that simplicity and for a high
running anxious person like me and you
right
we have to deal with why is our body
spinning and running and running and
running in that gap between safety
between a fully funded emergency fund
and a single account that's a sinking
fund
and so my challenge to you is to
simplify this process you're making it
way too complicated
and when you're not running and churning
and churning and running and checking on
this account trying to get this code for
this bank so you can log into that one
and check this
you're going to feel a little bit buzzy
a little bit anxious a little bit you're
not like you're not doing something i
want you to deal with that get to the
bottom of that feeling
and live a more aim for a more simple
life because the the word we use around
here instead of simplicity we we say
peace you can just go to sleep you can
just breathe see what i'm saying
i do but
and and this is definitely that
that working on that how do you then
keep track of what's supposed to be
where like
i have one account that has everything
in it how do you know what is suppo what
is available for
house repairs versus what is available
for like say splurging on a newer car
um there's these awesome things called
yellow pads and pins
um you can use an excel sheet what i'm
telling you is having multiple accounts
all over the place for this thing and
for that thing
is just try it another way for 60 days
and if it's a total flop then the banks
are going to be they're going to love
you coming back and opening up more
accounts
yeah and i think to alexis if you know
okay i need to replace a car so i'm
going to need
12 000 in this account to go and pay
cash for the car that i want and we're
going to have house repairs and all of
this so we're going to need like 6 500
here you then you just start doing the
math to say okay how much is in this
account okay uh when do i need the car
buy we have six months for that the
house repairs probably need to be done
in the next three months like you start
to just kind of for you just yeah you
just get a yellow pad out and a pen and
and start just kind of tracking it that
way
but some people do
have multiple accounts yeah george has
him he's got several accounts there are
people that definitely like this is my
vacation accounts all that i just am not
an organized person
so i literally would have
if i did that if i did that system for
my personality and i had 10 accounts i
would forget about four of them and then
i would get to heaven and jesus is like
oh rachel you had all these accounts
that you forgot about it's like i just i
couldn't keep you here's what you're
doing alexis you're dress rehearsing
tragedy
okay
you are looking into the future there's
a difference between hey our cars are
starting to age on us and so let's start
putting some let's start being
intentional about planning
and
we got to have a separate fund because
what if the air conditioner goes out and
if the air conditioner goes out then
that means the transmission is going to
fall out of the car right there's a
difference in those two actions
and one is borderline like but i'll
admit to it
borderline prepping
right you got meat in the freezer and a
year's worth of dry canned goods right
there's that and then there's just being
smart
and it's one of those causes a lot of
anxiety and perpetuates this motion
motion motion as though we're getting
somewhere and the other one is i want to
live a peaceful life being peaceful
means i got my i got food in case things
i get silly
but i'm also not going to have a hidden
freezer out back that i got to go check
every two weeks and i got right
i
i tried this rachel i had accounts all
over the place and it was sheila my wife
that finally came and said
can we could we just have for our okay
yes can we have one we have an emergency
fund and then our bank account and let's
just keep the stuff and
whoo
it just brought peace to our house the
simplicity of it yeah it's good
chaos is does not help chaos we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john deloney
joined by rachel cruz and we are taking
your calls on money taking your calls on
your relationships
and work whatever you got going on
we've probably got an opinion about it
or some expertise and give us a free
call at
825-5225 it's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's go to charlie in
tampa what's up charlie
hey john here rachel how are you all
doing today doing great thanks for
calling
good um well i have a question about uh
my wife and i have two children we have
a 15 year old boy and an eight-year-old
girl and um you know they've seen us in
their lifetime on you know the ramsay
plan and doing our steps and even the
oldest um
his envelope system when he you know got
a small allowance as a younger kid well
this summer he has his first full-time
job just during the summer
and uh he's you know making his first
paycheck he actually just got this past
friday
and um
i want to mention tithing to him he's
yeah his reply was yeah of course i'm
going to give something to the church
but was teaching him the 10 standard his
eyes got kind of wide because based on a
little 20 allowance here and there
that's a very small amount but when he's
looking at the 100 paycheck you know
that's a lot of money at first so the
question is um i just assumed that you
know we would require him to type being
you know his parents and him leaving our
home and following our example um my
wife's not at all opposed to that but
she brought the the possibility of him
being able to make the decision for
himself and just wanted to see what you
both thought on that
yeah it's a great question um
you know when it comes to giving i think
whether you're a parent teaching a child
or it's yourself
i
the legalistic
side always rubs me the wrong way so i'm
always we encourage 10 percent at ramsey
and i believe i we tithe 10 percent even
more winston myself um so i believe in
it a hundred percent but i i don't do it
because
it's a rule and it's an obligation
uh there's a heart change that occurs
when it comes to giving and so for him
um
you know i i think it's it's a great
exercise for him to learn to give period
right because you want to teach your
kids the things when they leave home
become adults of like here are the
habits here are the principles and the
values that i want to instill in you as
you know as a parent to a child so when
you leave home that almost this is
normal this is this is how you do life
and so giving is one of those things for
me so giving is non-negotiable now to
require 10
out of every paycheck for him
um
i don't know i mean
part of me is like i think it's kind of
up to you as the parent to decide what
it was and i was thinking with mom at my
parents when we got an allowance we did
have to give yeah cause we got like six
bucks or whatever a week when we were
kids and it was like yeah you gave a
dollar
it wasn't quite ten percent and you know
they were not very legalistic about it
uh and then when i got when i babysat
and worked at the mall and all of that
as a teenager i did give out of it but i
honestly cannot remember charlie if mom
and dad made us do the ten percent um so
for me it's left less of a math issue
and more of a heart issue for him and i
want him to have the heart of a giver
when he leaves home and not just like
the mathematics of i give ten percent
and that's what i do does that make
sense
it does no that's a good point more of
the spirit behind it that i want to
encourage as a parent here's here's how
it's how we do it in our house charlie
um very similar
is
i think two guiding principles here
number one uh rachel says that that more
is caught than is taught
and so i think this is he's old enough
now to sit down with you guys and do
your family budgets together
hank um is my son's 12
he probably sits through one out of
every three or four budgets now and he
rolls his oh gosh
sorry dude you got to sit down and watch
us do this
i want him to see that the first line in
our budget is giving and we've got you
know tithing but we've got places where
we give i want him to see this is how
mom and dad roll with their money he's
watching it happen sometimes we let him
hit the button to send payment x or
whatever that or this got automatically
drafted so we're showing him this is how
we do this the second thing is is i do
think it's important
to
like as there's a reason why
you're you're still the steward you're
still a custodian of that money right
you're still in charge of your kid and
so in our house we've said you will give
to something
giving is non-negotiable if at this age
in your life you are not choosing to
give here but you're going to give there
i'm going to let you make so that's
where the that's where the
decision-making capability is so he's
going to see my son is going to see
we give to this particular organization
that we believe in we tithe in this way
so every sunday morning hey the lights
are on here and the air conditioner
works here and
our pastors can get up on stage and feed
his family because we give
you will give but you're going to give
somewhere so that's where that latitude
comes in does that make sense because
i'm with rachel the last thing i want to
do is have a son who is counting dollars
in this on a spiral notebook
that he was forced to quote unquote
giveaway to a thing he doesn't you see
what i'm saying
no that's a good point um yeah very very
good to see that that perspective
because of you know we both have no
doubt that he is a very generous young
man we've seen that we just want to
continue to promote and and encourage
that and and no doubt that he'll be
blessed through that you know as we are
he sees he sees that and all the things
that you know we're blessed with
enabling you together that's no that's a
very great point and that's a good
takeaway yeah and and one thing too
charlie with parents that uh and
obviously you and your wife have done a
fabulous job i mean from what even
you've said in this call like man that's
such good intentional parenting uh when
it comes to money and your kids uh but
i'm not saying this is you but there are
some people that listen to this show
religiously and they are they are
hardcore and it is like there's no room
for mistakes and we're gonna make the
kids do everything perfect and we got
this
and well the motivation is good because
you're like i want my kids to learn this
i don't want them to make the mistakes i
made uh you have to give room for
mistakes for your kids to learn on their
own and so it's better for them to make
small inexpensive mistakes under your
roof versus going out in the real world
and the first time that they make a
mistake
uh you know that it's that it's out
there so i'm saying all this to say for
your son
say you guys said hey you have to give
but the amount you want to give we're
going to let you choose and let's just
pretend charlie he gives one percent and
he's like here's here's just a little
bit
and then maybe another month he's like
oh man i i do feel like i really love
this thing that i'm giving you i'm gonna
give a little bit more and he starts to
learn himself
the feeling of feeling of wow what the
joy of giving you know brings in him and
he's learning that at 15 versus it being
a mandate of that 10 so and one quick
side note i
i don't have any data on what i'm about
to tell you here's a decision i've made
in my wife and i've made our house
i've invited my son in to
he has a ballpark of how much money
comes into our house every month
and i i was left out of that
conversation growing up i had no idea um
and so i think that helps with
perspective when he says whoa whoa it
was way easier to put two dollars
in the i don't know the collection plate
whatever that looks when i made 20 bucks
it's hard to put 50 when i make
500
and you can say
yeah i make 75 000. here's what i'm
putting in right and so it helps norm
that scale right that question you're
asking it helps and again i know your
kid he could probably go run to school
and say can you believe my mom and dad
make this much we have had hard
conversations about don't talk about
money and this is the right way to do
this and let's be respectful and these
are private numbers et cetera but i've
just opted to yeah let him sit down and
say here's what's coming in and here's
what's going out i wanted to have a
picture of how the world works right yes
yes and that may backfire on me
no i don't think it will no i don't try
it
well
no i don't know i know in that fact yeah
that's a
it's i think it's so good to show
numbers to appoint
to to to your example of like okay
here's real world and here's what this
looks like and yeah here's how much
cable is comcast that work out of our
paycheck yeah those shows you watch
here's here's netflix and they're seeing
the dollars leave the paycheck like
literally
uh i think is yeah or it was it was the
it was the light bill was the one he saw
on the counter
and he was like how much yeah it was
staggering right to a middle schooler
you know however many hundreds of
dollars like i couldn't wrap my head
around that it's like when i tell you to
turn the lights off in your bedroom and
it was like oh
you know what i mean yeah when you crank
the air conditioner down to like it has
a cost to it right see mom and dad they
did that they shared certain things
specific numbers but they we never knew
how much they like maybe they just
didn't trust us yeah
i don't think they're like we're
absolutely not giving rachel any of that
information his son is so much more
trustworthy than we were
exactly hank
but hey he is important thing morgan and
a like i want to read it rachel said
grateful for your intentional parroting
and parenting if you want your kids to
start engaging in certain behaviors
remember they watch you way more than
they listen to you so if you want them
to be givers you be a giver you want
them to be generous you be generous how
you tip people how you love people how
you tithe and give if that's part of
your value system whatever that looks
like for you model it and be intentional
about teaching your kids
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
we are back and we've got
two
beautiful people up on the debt free
stage grady and amelia how we doing good
good i'm assuming that since y'all are
staying on the different stage that that
means y'all are here to do your
debt-free scream
we are excellent okay so where do you
live
charleston south carolina charleston
south carolina great spot great place
and how much have you all paid off
fifty five thousand one hundred and
forty dollars
fifty i love this specifically yeah not
that we're being specific to the dollar
excellent how long did it take
it took 14 months nice whoa 14 months
how much you're making um at the high
end we were making about 120. 120
per year what'd you start at
um it kind of varies because i got a job
and then i um with covet i started
working more hours um so it was closer
to like 110. 110 man so you all did
y'all you all went for it
yeah that's amazing what do you do for a
living
i'm in the i'm in the navy okay and i'm
a nurse
wonderful thank you both i would say
thank you both for your jobs good grief
okay so what happened 14 months ago and
you're like okay we got 55 000 and what
was the debt was it student loans was it
credit cards um it was a car it was a
truck it was a motorcycle um and then
the worst one was like my family loan
but we owed my parents money
why did you take a family loan um i was
young and dumb with money and uh
it bit man you're a family loan yours
your family so her family uh loaned us
some money because i i had uh
a couple of loans that were up to 28
interest and we just couldn't handle it
so they said hey we'll yeah pay it off
and then you just pay us with low
interest or no interest or whatever it
was okay was that the best one to get
rid of yeah sorry mom and dad
okay hold on
what was it like going to your
father-in-law and mother-in-law and
saying
uh
i'm i'm in the navy and i have a really
cool jacked up truck and a motorcycle
kind of borrow some money walk us
through that
um so that was more of her doing she
kind of did that going to went to her
mom and was just kind of like
we're moving and
i'm about to not have a job and i don't
see how we're going to make it and her
mom was kind of like okay well we can we
can loan you all the money and
and pay off that and then y'all can
slowly start
paying us back yeah and that was our
number one that we paid off okay yeah
how much of that was the 55 um it was
started at 28 000 okay
but by the time we started dave ramsey's
program it was about 22. okay okay
awesome awesome awesome so half of that
was that family loan okay so what
happened it got you
how did you come up with us weirdos
how'd you get connected to this whole
crazy crew what happened so she was um
she had already heard of dave ramsey and
was uh doing the debt snowball but it um
it only works so well with one person
and then our church had the uh fpu
and so she said hey we should go to this
and we went and i think within a couple
of weeks i was
on board going we could do this
okay so what changed your mind then what
was the thing that that clicked for you
in that class or what we always said
that you're like okay this is this could
be doable
seeing the reality of it saying seeing
the numbers work and just seeing so many
people that were successful in it and it
was kind of like okay that could be us
that's amazing how old are you guys 28.
oh my gosh 28 and no debt
how do you have a house payment do you
live on base
um so we live on base in charleston
south carolina and have a house payment
in georgia which we're moving there at
the end of this month okay okay cool
man y'all congratulations thank you i
mean you did it and it's one of those
things like no matter what season of
life you're in it's hard right so you
could be
55 with old kids you could be in the
middle of uh you know your 30s with
littles or you could be single right
whatever whatever the the life situation
is it's doable for anyone
uh but for you guys what was the hardest
part though you're in your late 20s
you're more established you have good
jobs
you're like we are living on nothing and
throwing all of our money at this debt
how what was hard about that
um
the fact that i'm i'm in a a stage that
i'm not deploying and it's one of those
that we instead of going out and
celebrating and playing
we were spending all of our money on
debt and trying to get that paid off so
the time that
we had the most time together we weren't
getting to really go out and enjoy wow
that is hard you sacrificed a lot
yeah i think the hardest part for me was
that we work different schedules and i
work night shift and he goes to work at
seven in the morning and i get home at
like 8 30 a.m
and so we were just kind of like ships
passing in the night um and so like the
most sometimes i would see him would be
for dinner
and that can just be really hard and
then when the hours were there i would
work more and so that was pretty hard
okay so talk to people listening because
that's one reason a lot of people don't
say hey we're not going to go all in
because i want to you know spend time
with my spouse which is a very normal i
got a little kid and i can't do it yeah
yeah which is very you know like heroic
i get that absolutely but what would you
say to someone
14 months later completely debt free
was it worth it
absolutely because now it's what we have
is ours we don't owe anyone
um
it's ours yeah for the the freedom of
being able to like because we know we're
moving at the end of this month and so
the freedom of being able to move and
not question
how are we going to make this month work
and
you know we don't live anywhere near our
family so
as like my grandparents get older and as
things happen you know we can't when
you're when you have the debt there and
it's hanging over your head
and something happens and you're like
well we need to go home we need to
um have that ability you don't have that
ability when you're like i can't i can't
make it all work
absolutely yeah that's incredible you
guys wow well done what's what's the
the thing that you had to sell that
still hurts a little bit
um honestly we got by without
selling
really anything oh you just paid it all
off
sheer so you got to keep the truck and
the motorcycle
look at him smiling like yeah
he even got some upgrades to the
motorcycle too oh of course he did very
cool but guys i'm so proud of you uh who
are your biggest cheerleaders
um probably our fpu leaders which um
they are probably listening um alicia
and jamie and some of our friends at our
church um the edwards's and um the
gatewoods and your parents and my
parents obviously um
just those people were definitely in our
corner and we celebrated everything with
them what was the if y'all could distill
it down into one key takeaway what was
the number one key to getting out of
that together
i would probably say just keep trying
just just keep um you know some months
uh i think three months in our dogs got
into like
three pounds of chocolate and so we had
to pay two thousand dollars
at the emergency vet
um and so that was really hard um and
just just keep trying like the shared
grit like things are gonna happen along
the way um murphy's law is a real thing
so just
just keep re-buckling down and keep
going well for two people who
give your most
precious resource to all of us which is
your time and you give your talents and
you give your life to everybody both of
you on behalf of everybody my little
kids rachel's little kids thank you
and for your example showing us hey it's
i'm gonna not see the person i love the
most in the world for 14 months
so that i can see
that knucklehead a guy or that beautiful
i can see them whenever i want right um
y'all did it you made the sacrifice
grady and amelia from charleston south
carolina soon to be georgia paid off 55
140
in 14 months
110 to 120 000
unbelievable it's a
navy
stud and a nurse stud
is that the way to say that i'm just
getting this awkward as possible
count them down to your debt free scream
three two
one we're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing oh amazing and hey we're going
to give you a copy of dave's number one
best-selling book total money makeover
so you can gift that to somebody who
needs it we're also going to give you a
copy of baby steps millionaires because
that's the next step
journey unbelievable rachel incredible i
love it that's what we talked about all
the time and they did it i can listen to
jeffrey screams all day so great
congratulations you guys
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
eight two five five two two five this is
the ramsay show let's go out to morgan
in pocatello idaho rachel's favorite
place in the united states what's up
morgan
hey how are you guys remarkable how are
you
doing good excellent hey um
i just have a question when
you don't have holiday pay how do you
budget for months that are short
for memorial day labor day
fourth of july christmas thanksgiving
you know they're coming and you know
they're going to be short so you take
money
for instance june we had an extra
paycheck because we got five paychecks
we usually get four and so do you take
that money from june on your fifth
paycheck and just budget it towards july
for the fourth of july or
do you just work that into your budget
and kind of cut down on other expenses
so are you getting paid hourly and
whenever you get i'll have a holiday
then you don't get paid on that day
yes it's my husband my husband works and
yes he doesn't get holiday pay he's a
union electrician okay and they don't
have holiday pay yeah so you can either
yeah limit some expenses for that month
if you want or i would just keep a
buffer morgan um
as we're talking about all these
different accounts we could have but
when you're on commission and or i don't
know yep in a sense this is kind of the
same um idea because some months may be
higher some months may be lower and to
make sure what is in your budget is
getting paid you could have a buffer
account that you have some money in and
you're like okay on the months
sagan it's not like a zero-based account
like i can have like an extra thousand
dollars in our chicken account that's
not my emergency fund correct yes and a
zero-based budget does not mean zero in
your checking account so you don't wanna
you don't wanna you don't wanna do each
month where you literally have nothing
in your checking account you do wanna
buffer because stuff is going to come up
and i don't want you yet going into the
red in your checking account um so yeah
so i would have your thousand dollar
emergency fund and then just say okay
we're going to keep and it doesn't have
to be a ton because there's not that
many holidays and it's just one day
um so it doesn't july we're having july
we're short too because there's a
holiday in july that we celebrate in
idaho okay that he has work off that the
rest of the nation doesn't celebrate and
so
you know
and so it comes up and i sort of kind of
knew i kind of i had my how to i had a
moment last week and so i'm like
cranking down and
it's refreshing
in our house we call it our lag account
and we're on commission i'm on
commission too and so that's that's
exactly the way we do it and we worked
over the last few years so that
i can we're i'm always paying the next
month's
bills
with
most of what was left in the checking
account that makes sense we zero base
every month but i've got that lag
account there and i can't let you go
what is the holiday that idaho like
celebrates that the rest of us don't
so idaho and utah both celebrate the
24th of july
it's the day that utah became a state
but we live in a county that is
basically utah but we're in idaho yeah
it's like pick them up right
all right we have them
right we sometimes we we call ourselves
cash valiant but we don't live in that
county if that makes sense man you
totally celebrate so they became a state
pick it up tennessee why aren't we what
are we doing hey texas celebrates that
every day of the year
they're always celebrating how y'all
became how the hell
exactly hey well thank you so much for
call morgan let's go out to carla in uh
atlanta what's up carla
hey thank you john and rachel for taking
my call i really appreciate it you got
it what's up
um so i am a single mom and i am
i'm done with uh baby step number three
so i'm excited to have money in the bank
and my debt gone yeah congratulations
thank you i felt great relief from that
um but now i'm struggling to find peace
because
i just have this overwhelming sense that
i'm running out of time
um i'm 46 i have like 20 plus years of
work ahead of me
but um i think
part of it may be i'm a mom of
four children ranging from 21
to 7
and i feel like i lost a bunch of time
with my older kids
because i wasn't in a financially good
place
and now
i'm like trying to figure out how to
save for a car save for a possible
wedding for my oldest
um save for a house like all these
things that i want to do and accomplish
but i feel like i'm running out of time
so two things are at play here okay
number one you have to set that guilt
down
you didn't miss out on your kids you you
work to keep that thing running
okay
i want you to um this is going to sound
so cheesy but i want you to do this i
want you to go
to home depot and buy a brick paver and
i want you to duct tape on it
lost time with kids
i want you to carry it around for a bit
10 or 15 minutes
and then i want you to set it down
and never pick it up again
okay okay
the second thing is the only thing you
can control moving forward is what your
time is with your kids like with the
kids that are at home right
yeah you can make that change whatever
that change looks i don't think it's as
bad as you think it is um you may want
to sit down with one of your older kids
and say i am haunted by the guilt that i
didn't show up for y'all because i was
too busy trying to get my stuff together
have that conversation with them they
may free you or they may confirm it and
then y'all can grieve it together and
then move on about your day
and then when it comes to these expenses
at the end of the day
the best you can do is write down your
expenses and tackle them as they come
but what you're doing right now is
you're robbing from your
current present joy
with future problems that haven't
happened yet
see what i'm saying got it
yeah no i do i do i just have
felt so
stuck
in trying to free myself from that it's
great like
it's calling it yeah exactly it
absolutely is grief you're gonna have to
grieve it um i'm gonna give you hang on
the line i'm gonna send you a copy of my
latest book on your past change of
futures a whole chapter on grief as a
society we're terrible at it
right we're terrible at sitting down and
saying
i wanted it to look like this
and here's reality
and you got to sit in that for a minute
and then there's some some really clear
paths out of that grief
and experiencing it and some of that
great's going to go forever you're going
to always like regret man i missed this
and i didn't show up for that because i
was busy working
and at one point your kid's going to
look at you and say yeah but we had a
roof and we had food and i love you and
i'm so grateful for you right yeah
yes absolutely
hey for whatever it's worth you're
you're worth being well
well thank you
and for the first time in a long time um
i want you to start being nice to our
new friend carla
because you're mean to her is that fair
i am
you're mean to carla don't i like carla
too all the expenses you're talking
about are legitimate right a wedding
is the car for you or one of your kids
for myself eventually okay absolutely
right now has paid off i just wanna yeah
upgrade and all that yeah
and you know and all of that is on a
spectrum
and there could be a point that you say
because of where you're at financially
of like hey i'm a single mom i have a
single income coming in and so my
upgrade on my car may be just this even
though i would love this maybe it's this
for this time because i'm going to spend
time with my kids
and not work extra to get a crazy
upgrade on the car or maybe for the
wedding
it's hey i'm gonna do the best i can to
save but i'm also
going to realize that what is more
important as a mom and who i am to my
kids
is being present with them
being in conversation with them asking
them questions knowing them being with
them
all of that carries such weight carla
for your kids into their adult life more
than you paying for a wedding even
though i want you to do that and i think
it's a very noble goal um but i think
you know just just i think take the
pressure off i think i think you're
doing a much better job than you're
giving yourself credit for it and i want
you to grieve those pictures she just
mentioned you have a picture of yourself
at 50
in this
dope i don't know escalade are you an
escalade kind of lady like you have like
this awesome escalade and it might not
happen you might be you might be right
in a corolla and you have this picture
of a wedding you're going to be able to
lavishly it may not happen grieve that
picture and then come back to reality
and live there you're doing great carla
you're a good mom you're such a good mom
hey that's the first hour in the books
here on the ramsay show stay with us
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
three
[Music]
this is all about your character you can
have money and a career you are the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation
about your money
your life your relationships just about
anything and everything i'm john deloney
joined here by my good friend rachel
cruz and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two
five let's go out to amanda in new york
city what's up amanda
hi guys how are you thank you for taking
my call good how are you
i'm all right i'm looking for a little
bit of advice i think my situation is a
little unique but trying to look for a
little bit of color
um
so i work full time at a law firm and my
boss was the idea of applying to law
school and
inheriting the firm in the event that i
was accepted
so i was recently accepted um and so now
i'm trying to deal with payment of
tuition
i'm also fortunate in that my boss is
funding half of the tuition and take my
responsibility to fund the other half
um
my husband and i were in the middle of
baby step two when i got my acceptance
and so we paused the bandit steps to try
to cash flow as much of law school as we
could
but we do still have some student loan
debt
from previous from my undergrad
and so i'm trying to deal with
the guilt of the possibility of having
to take on
additional student loan debt um while
also still trying to balance what seems
like
a really great opportunity
uh i don't think those things are
mutually exclusive
okay it is a great opportunity it's
pretty cool
your boss clearly sees something in you
and is willing to put um his
money where his mouth is right
right there's very few things more
flattering than that i think somebody
telling you uh you're my person and i'll
spend the rest of my life with you is
really flattering
and a boss that calls you in and says i
see so much in you and you go get extra
training and i'm willing to to foot part
of that bill that's awesome
and right i was a dean of students at a
law school for for
a long time and the law school debt is
crippling
and the panic and the anxiety and the
frustration and the movements
professionally
that happens
makes me tell you do not go into debt
and it can still be a great opportunity
and not the right time for this great
opportunity
and if your boss says
it's now or never then he's giving you a
hint into his character in a way that
you may not want to tether yourself to
him for the next four five ten years
if he says absolutely understand
circle back to me and you and your
husband get really intense and save up
the cash because i think the
a law degree is one of the single
greatest credentials you can have i
think it's a super valuable thing and
i'm in awe of people who go through that
process
i just wouldn't borrow money to do it
and i know that's hard what i'm saying i
know that
yeah it's definitely like a hard pull to
tell only because my husband and i are
in our 30s so i'm going back like a
little bit later in general and so how
much longer do you have left amanda
i shouldn't started yet i haven't
started oh you haven't oh i think
here's what i know i'm supposed to be
starting in august did you get into an
ivy league school
no okay i'm going to a local school it
is private i was given
a partial
scholarship so the entirety of the bill
between the two of us is 30 000. he's
paying for half of that and i would be
responsible for 15. my husband and i
after buckling down cash flowed like or
pleased up enough cash flow half of that
and so i would hypothetically be taking
out a loan for the balance yeah i i i
wouldn't
i just wouldn't do that i'd rather say
one go in and defer your admission which
i don't outside of an ivy league school
that's just got an incredible admissions
pressure i don't know a law school that
wouldn't defer in this current climate
the the tables have turned at most law
schools where they're looking for
students when i was trying to go to law
school back in the day i was thinking
about it
it was very very few seats and a lot of
students and that's flipped and so you
can go defer your admission for one year
and tell your boss man i'm all in i love
this idea it's just not financially
feasible for us my guess is he's gonna
say what's it gonna cost
and if you've got some skin in the game
he may meet that otherwise he may say
cool and say we're going to make this
work in the fall my husband are going to
save up a bunch of money and we're going
to go forward with it and if he asks you
you can say we just don't do debt in our
house
and if he's got a visceral response
that's negative to that i think that
gives you a long-term picture of who
you're working for quite honestly who's
gonna and it's just he's looking at one
of your values and saying well that's
stupid i'm like and i just don't know if
he's gonna do that i don't think he's
gonna go i don't think he's going to i
think he values you a lot
and amanda do you um
how does that hit you though waiting a
year just say all of that worked out
right you were able to defer
save up the money and have it
to go in a year what is that what does
that do to you
i just don't know if
within a year you would be able to save
that amount of money because over the
course of i'm doing a part-time program
because i would be working full-time and
going to school part-time and so it's
four years versus three
um and i just can't be like saving
what would be forty thousand dollars in
a year yeah but after that i mean you're
talking about raises you're talking
about externships where you're gonna get
paid i mean there's all different ways
especially once you get out of your 1l
year there's ways to get part-time job i
mean there's ways to make this work
with additional resources you're really
struggling to get through the first year
and a half if not two years and then
after that the game changes quite a bit
uh how how old are you
we're 32. that's the other okay that's
the other edition so i i i told this
story in in
my latest book here my wife was talking
to a couple of friends who were um i
think they were 35
and both of them they're all hanging out
and one of them said you know what like
i really kicked myself cause i should
have gone to law i mean to med school
and
this person's spouse said me too like
that's my dream to always go to med
school but we're 35 and we won't be
actually out practicing medicine
on our own until we're 42
and my wife who's very very wise said
that's not the question
the question is
uh or you're going to be 42.
the question is do you want to be
doctors when you're 42 or not
so i would tell you is you're going to
be 36 you're going to be 37.
do you want to be a lawyer when you're
37 or not a lawyer when you're 37.
that's the real question and if you want
to be a lawyer when you're 37 take a
year work like crazy have your husband
pick up a second job because this is a
family shift and you know as well as i
do law school's really hard on everybody
right
so that when i'm 37
i'm gonna take the back two-thirds of my
life and be an attorney and go help the
least of these or do whatever we're
doing with our law firm does that make
sense
yeah it's real real easy
it is it's so hard it's so so hard
especially when it feels like i've got a
deal that i've got to move on right this
second or it all comes down yeah if
you're backed into a corner that way i'd
let the deal pass that's it you all you
never make really good decisions when
you don't have a lot of options and it's
like it's either now or never
you're gonna make bad decisions on that
that's right yeah so just like take a
breath and
and and i think it's gonna be okay i
mean i think i think it's gonna force
you to ask different questions and to
maybe engage in conversations that are
uncomfortable but it's worth it to do it
so that you don't tackle you don't put
all this debt on you guys here in the
next few months that's exactly right i
think you're gonna end up in law school
you're gonna do great things and you're
not gonna owe anybody anything we'll be
right back
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two three five i'm
john delony joined here by
rachel
cruz
rachel we got an event coming up tell us
about it yeah we're excited about this
um it's
crazy just the real estate market right
now i feel like so many people are
talking about it there's so much doom
and gloom and people are thinking oh
what's gonna happen to the housing
prices
but
we here at ramsey like to focus on facts
not feelings we like to look at the data
of what's going on so next week we're
doing a free real estate reality check
live stream so it's a one night special
on july 14th george campbell myself and
dave ramsey we're going to help you
understand how the market actually works
and then how to navigate it right now
so we're just saying right now from what
everything looks like it's not going to
crash we're not going into a deep deep
depression like some people are saying
on tick tock and instagram and the news
so we're going to show you the facts
behind it and why it's actually still a
good time to buy and sell so don't miss
this event again it's thursday july 14th
next thursday and you can register for
the event
right now for free if you go to
ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck i think it's important to
put
to put a pin in this real quick um
let's say you got in a
car wreck when you were 15
and you were making a left turn and you
were stopped at the intersection and
somebody just t-boned you
your brain
which is a prediction machine and a
threat detection system that's what it
does
anytime you
move into a left lane to make a left
turn an intersection your heart rate's
going to go up a little bit your body
remembers this moment and it remembers
we got t-boned here we got look look out
look out right and even though
everything's fine right and you're going
to start your stress response is going
to kick in for you to defend you because
you're only our bodies remember this how
scared our parents were how all the
sudden home prices dropped off the news
was do that was really what i feel like
the doom and gloom news kicked in and
became a sensational thing
and so as we're getting into yeah right
maybe we're heading towards a recession
the stock market's all crazy we're
everybody's struggling with with
finances inflation's out of control
our bodies remember and it starts saying
look out look out look out look outside
right and that's where i think this
event is so important because the
antidote to that
is
facts it's truth right is actual data
not
um
following that fear into the middle of
the intersection assuring that you're
getting iraq right right right
absolutely yeah so most of us have been
through this before
it's when you got to step back
jaco says you got to detach right you
gotta exhale and say okay what is the
data what's this real situation look
like what's it saying yep and yeah and
there's just something about that
panic
and oh because you know me i'll have a
good conspiracy theory so even those you
know it's like oh my gosh what's going
on you know you kind of are you're in it
and you're kind of freaking out and you
start making decisions
in that world and in that mindset and
it's like no you can't do that you can't
do that you have to look at the facts of
what's going on
and in a weird way the facts are not as
exciting and ooh crazy and talkative you
know they're like there's not like major
big talking points of how exciting the
actual facts and the data are of like
what i mean facts i mean like how many
homes legitimately are for sale
legitimately how many new homes what is
what does you know supply and demand
look like i mean these are how many
buyers are there yeah this is facts so
we're going to give it to you but it's
uh it'll be great and it's just a good
to bring you hope too in this time
because that's right it's all about hope
yes that it's okay we're going to be
okay yes our price is higher than they
were in 2019 absolutely yes
so we're gonna do about it so we're
going to do about it so it's um i'm glad
you all are doing this i'm glad you're
just bringing some
you know some facts and some data and
some peace to this that's madness man
that's so good let's go to julie in
raleigh what's up julie
hey guys how are you doing good how are
you
doing great uh first of all thank you
for changing our financial future i
really appreciate all the help you guys
give
today i wanted to ask about cell phones
we are thinking of upgrading our phones
possibly in the fall
and there are some specials going where
you essentially get a i'm going to call
it a free phone
and they will charge your they will add
that payment to your bill over three
years but then they give you that same
amount back as a credit over that same
period of time
instead of us shelling out a thousand
dollars per phone
is it okay to just get that free phone
over the period of time if it's not
costing us anything
what's the credit back say that again
so they'll they'll charge your bill each
month for the phone for let's say 25 but
then they credit that same 25 back on
that same bill
okay so their way of accounting two
things here first one is
anytime there's a scheme like this which
is what it is right
i always want to know what's the
long-term play
so we know a company
whose business is making money that's
their job
they are not gonna give away a thousand
dollar cell phone because they're nice
so what will they get
by quote-unquote giving you a free phone
or basically loaning it to you for three
years
and giving you a fake charge and a fake
credit a neutral credit
what are they getting
in return
our service for the next three years
plus what
at the end of this three years you're
gonna look down and you are gonna feel
so good because you have earned through
your hard work and dedication
another three year contract with him in
a free phone
see what i'm saying
so they it's
what i would say there's there is no
free anything it's always going to come
at a cost and so i want to know what am
i get what what are they getting out of
handing me a thousand dollar
computer that's number one number two is
i have an inversion and i don't rachel
you can talk to me more about the talk
about the ramsey policy but i have an
aversion to anybody who is trying to
quote unquote own me down the road and
so my funny story is i walked into i was
i think i was an att customer at the
time i walked in and said um i need to
get a new i'm going to be a new customer
and they started automatically enrolling
me into this
program where you know i i said i want
to pay cash right now for this phone and
it took three different people and
finally one guy goes nobody's ever done
this before and he's like can you just
roll it into the payment plan and i said
i can't sleep at night knowing that i
owe you money for this depreciating
asset in my pocket
can i just pay you a check i mean pay
cash for right now and they figured out
they finally took my money to their
credit right i took my credit they took
my money but
i can't sleep knowing that i owe
somebody money it drives me crazy right
so i personally i opt out of the system
yes i don't yeah that's why i told
people just yeah just buy it up front do
you have the money julie
yes yeah i just buy it and you don't
think you don't think about it again and
you're not kind of stuck playing that
game of what john was even talking about
of oh this and this and this and this
and this and this so for me i'm like
yeah by the phone just get the phone
it's yours and then you're with them in
your contract for three years or even if
you want to opt out it doesn't mess
anything up down the road so yeah
anything that's going to be
tied down that you're tied to them in
the future is what they're wanting so
i yeah i would just pay for it julie or
if their service interrupts or something
goes sideways there's so many things
that happen three years from now
i'd rather just have my phone i
appreciate you thank you and
even if that cost me a little
quote-unquote more money right but it'll
be really hard if you've got crummy
service and it's been frustrating and i
think i want to change or their towers
aren't working so good or somebody built
a building and now the service isn't so
great three years later
but i've got that credit on my bill
for that free phone if i just keep it
i'll just go ahead and have right so now
i'm stuck now i'm i'm in the middle of
this thing so
it's up yeah i mean it is it's that form
of someone owing you
owning you that's right to a degree and
it may not seem like that big of a deal
julian may be like oh it's just a phone
and listen this is the way everyone does
it
but hey what if yeah what if all this
comes true and it's like you know what
man when the users have the freedom to
decide even something as small as your
cell phone service
it's peace at night it's just it's just
living your life in freedom complete
freedom yeah rachel for me it's it's
become it's it's almost a rabbit hole
for me but it's it's just following that
thread
who else has their hooks in me like who
who else who else who else who else even
to the point that sheila came back and
she's like hey stop sending
four months of
money to the electric company right
let's just pay the monthly bills like no
i don't want them to i don't want them
to ever right yeah yeah yeah i went too
far but it was i don't want anybody's
hooks even as small as a cell phone if
it's as big as a fill in the blank i
just want to be free make my own
decisions yeah it's good it's good all
right we'll be right back triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey forget it
if you're worried about money it's all
consuming
you wonder if you got enough money for
your bills or if you can even afford to
fill up at the gas station it's always
on your mind and it's weighing you down
and it's getting in the way of
relationships you're waking up in the
middle of the night this is a scary time
but listen you shouldn't have to live
with that kind of stress and you don't
have to when you follow a proven plan
you'll discover peace with your money
in financial peace university you'll
learn the same plan that's helped almost
10
million people budget
save and spend wisely pay off debt and
build wealth now listen
it's not going to be a bunch of
fireworks like uh some tick tock
influencer that's like yeah yeah it's
not
it's a plan
and it works every time
and now is a great time to take the
course because we just updated a ton of
the content plus me and george campbell
are now part of it too all new videos
decide today that you're done letting
money stress rule your life and i don't
know anybody who's not stressing about
their money you can do this get started
with financial peace university by
visiting ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash f
fpu all right let's go to jeff in macon
georgia hey jeff what's up man
all right how you doing outstanding
brother how are you
just fine it's hot as it can be but
we're getting by it is warm outside here
yes what's up man how can we help
uh
i've been listening to y'all's uh
program here for just a little bit not a
whole lot and i've got a little bit of
debt not much
but uh my question is uh buying versus
building i personally own a property and
uh
i've got a modular home on it that's
paid for
it's not a very old and it's like a
triple wide i guess it's one of the
kings of the double-wide trailer but uh
he uh i was looking at king of the
double wife i am
yeah buying a new house because i've
actually got like i'm 40 years old
and i've been working at my job for 23
years oh wow so that you know i mean
that that put me starting at 18.
and uh i've got a uh just like a
government job i work with a
municipality
and i've got 10 more years to work i can
retire at 50
51 and a half
as my set retire date and uh
i'm not saying that i'm not going to
work past him but i probably won't work
here past then that's when i'll probably
start making real money
but uh
anyway my question is buying a house
versus building a house and around here
where i'm at houses are i mean they're
high than what they were but they're not
super super high like
everywhere else in the world but uh like
i said i do have a piece of property i
do have a slab that's on this piece of
property that i was going to make you
know my shop
but i don't mind giving it up for you
know if i build a house on it and i
could probably be involved in lot in the
building aspect because i mean i work
for public works i'm a gas
uh superintendent so i mean i know a lot
about plumbing building electrical and
stuff like that
okay so jeff so you said you don't have
a lot of debt how much is not a lot of
debt
uh i've got 12 000 and uh i'll probably
have it paid out
probably first of next year and it's all
linked on one car
uh and i've got a bunch of toys and that
was the other thing i was gonna ask
about is uh i've got bass boats
my wife's car is paid for my truck's
paid for i've got i do a lot of missing
with automobiles
like his projects and i've got
several vehicles that i could sell
yeah okay so how much do you make a year
jeff you you and your wife combined i
don't i don't my wife isn't able to work
because she has to keep our grandkids
and uh so it's pretty much me the sole
provider i make about 62 to 65 000 a
year okay
at my job and uh that's my taxable
income and do y'all have any other
savings
i keep about you know 1000 to 1500 uh
just before a rainy day i guess it's
probably not near enough rain but i have
a lot of sick leave time
i've accumulated as you would think i
mean
being there that long i get one day
every year every month so i mean i've
got like 960 cash cash though cash
yeah cash i've just yeah maybe 1500
bucks cash are you guys living in the
king of the double wide right now
yes correct that's where you guys are
okay
you know honestly jeff i don't i don't
feel like i would i would not
i don't feel like you're in a good
position to buy a house or to build
right now so if i were you guys i would
pay off this 12 000 and that could be
selling some of the toys you were
talking about that you have
selling all that throwing it at this
debt but cleaning this debt up uh and
then saving for an actual emergency fund
so that'll be three to six months of
expenses
and then beyond that start looking at
okay what do we want our how the house
situation to look like and so
uh building naturally is always gonna be
a little bit more expensive but you can
always go and price it out and just say
hey if i have a builder come in and
since you're great with trade you're
gonna be able to help out you said you
know maybe things that you you don't
have to probably build it myself yeah
honestly so i would just i would look
then yeah so i would look to see okay
how long is it gonna take us to pay off
this debt if we're aggressive and pay
things off how long is it gonna take us
to get a fully funded emergency fund and
then what's that date and then have a
date in your mind
so maybe let's just for easy math we'll
just say next july so a year from now
uh we can start looking to see okay
we're going to start looking at the
house situation and so price out some
homes in the area right now and just say
hey here's uh the kind of homes we like
here's what we're thinking and then back
out into the math and say you know the
way we we present when you take out a
mortgage is that you want to put at
least
um gosh five ten percent down uh ideally
20 so you can avoid pmi and they get a
15-year fixed straight mortgage and that
payment be no more than 25 of your
take-home pay
and so use that formula to kind of kind
of look around at homes in your area and
see if there's any home that you're like
oh yeah that would be awesome to buy
we'll you know we like something like
that in that area
and if not and maybe you say hey let's
price out building
and again putting in your trade what
you're good at look at supplies all of
it and just price it out and then it
really just becomes a decision for you
and your wife to make to say hey here's
what we can afford
uh here's what the house would be if we
built it here's a home that we could buy
a pre-existing home um and you guys make
that call then but i would not do that
while you still have this 12 grand and
no savings
yeah i could get rid of the the debt
tomorrow just by selling uh like it's
attached to a camaro that i've got and
i've i've already had like dealerships
has offered me 16 for it that i so i
could actually do it four five five more
if i'm you i do it tomorrow
and i'd have four thousand dollars
towards towards my emergency fund
already
okay so i mean like i said i mean that
and i've got like
i mean i'm not trying to be you know
i've got grandkids you know and i i use
like this this fourth we spent the whole
weekend on the water i've got a pontoon
boat and i could i could literally asset
and liquidate everything i've got to
probably
not including the camaro to like 45
grand easy because i've got a 30 foot
fifth wheel that's paid for i've got two
other boats just paid for
and i was just going to get rid of
everything but like the camper in the in
the pontoon boat and everything else can
go you know jeff here's what here's what
i promise you if you go do that
and you get honest about cleaning up
your property and you get honest about
getting rid of just all these projects
and the cars and stuff
number one you have a rare ability that
most of the people that call the show
don't have and that's to flip a light
switch
you could have a fully funded emergency
fund and be completely debt free in
seven days
yeah and i was debt-free until i got the
win and got feeling old and thought i
wanted to buy this darn car but
hey we all made dumb mistakes with our
money it's about getting up and dusting
ourselves off and going again
then you can get serious about buying a
house it would be unethical for rachel
and i to tell you you know what you need
to go buy a house right now because one
thing or two things go wrong on that
house and you're gonna be in a mess so
dude sell the stuff
and then
you're talking
a week two weeks three weeks you're
completely different you get a fully
funded emergency fund and then you and
your wife can sit down and have a fun
conversation which is
not what do we have to do but what do we
want to do
what do we want this thing to look like
what do we want our back half of our
life to be man and i think that's a
whole different conversation then what
can we afford and how we're gonna
squeeze this thing out but you're in a
great position man
and i promise you she's gonna be real
happy without all those cars and boats
and everything out on the lawn
man you're gonna give her her yard back
to you that's gonna be awesome we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined by rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on money and on life
on anything else you got going on let's
go out to anthony in kansas city
missouri what's up anthony
oh what's going on how you doing we're
doing all right brother how are you
i'm pretty good it's hot over here so
it is cool making its way across the
country here so what's up dude how can
we help
hey i was just calling today because i'm
trying to get some advice on starting a
budget trying to get out of debt
um i don't have any
clue on where to start
i downloaded the every dollar app and
still don't know
where to start on anything so
all right starting from scratch
so anthony yeah so um what what's what
is your situation how much debt do you
have do you have any savings kind of
where you at
um i don't have any savings i don't have
anything like i i own my mobile home
um i'm about i would say about
15 000 in debt
okay um including my car
is that car credit card student loans
um it's
more like hospital bills
okay and
like some cell phone service stuff okay
and how much do you make a year
uh 31 000 okay
what do you do
um i do have a forklift for
for hostess actually okay yeah yeah
awesome okay
well anthony i mean yeah i think one of
the best starting places and what you
did which is great is is the budgeting
um when you do a budget there is this
level of feeling completely in control
of your money and for you maybe for the
first time ever where you're thinking oh
gosh you know i don't know i'm getting
my paycheck in i have no clue where it's
going
and so what you want to do is you want
to do it before the month begins so
we're here in july right now
the beginning of july so you could even
say i'm going to start this in august so
august 1
and you're going to look at your budget
for august you're going to look at your
expenses everything from your yeah if
you have a payment on the mobile home
to electricity water uh food and you're
gonna go down the list and every dollar
has suggested categories already in that
budget so you may could take some of
those out if they don't apply to you you
can add some
and then you're gonna put dollar amounts
next to all of those categories
and the goal is your income for august
minus all of those categories including
giving and saving in your case will
equal zero
so every dollar coming in in august is
assigned to a category you know exactly
where your paycheck's going
and since you're starting out kind of at
a clean slate
your goal really is a thousand dollar
emergency fund that's your number one
goal before paying off debt and so you
can use your budget then
to be your guide to say hey
what can i cut are there things i can
bring in extra income could i get a side
you know a side gig at night uh how's
the way to raise my income
and where can i cut expenses in my
budget realistically i'm not asking you
to like spend 20 in food for the month
or something right you want to be
realistic about your budget um but it's
a great guide to say hey here's where my
money's going where can i cut to get
that thousand dollars quickly
and quickly anthony i mean you're
changing your entire life right now when
we're talking about money like if you
have not been on
any kind of system any kind of plan
this is a complete
mindset shift that you're about to
experience so things are going to be new
it's going to be uncomfortable you're
going to do things you've never done
before but that's a good thing because
you want to start winning with money
which means you're going to do things
you've never done before and so
that budget and getting that thousand
dollars that's gonna that's your first
goal and really it's kind of the thing
that i always tell people it gives you a
sense of confidence
and the budget will take about three
months to work so august will probably
be a disaster and that's okay give
yourself grace september it'll kind of
work october it's like okay buy no buy
buy christmas for sure by thanksgiving
you're gonna say okay i get it like i i
know i i feel in control and that's
gonna be able to guide you to getting
that thousand dollars and also start
working your way out of debt
i just did a lot of talking i did a lot
of talking with you yeah what questions
do you have
no that's perfectly fine i i definitely
appreciate it um
so a couple questions i have is at the
moment i'm currently behind on quite a
bit of bills uh
my gas for my house is
about a thousand behind my car payment's
behind about a thousand
um and then i just got back that way
like what what happened that didn't
happen overnight that doesn't happen one
month that's two or three or four or
five months
yeah so i have a terrible spending habit
for impulse buying okay on
pretty much every paycheck so like i'll
pay
what i think i can pay and then i'll be
like oh i have 200 left i have to have
200 left for myself
okay um for for
for random stupid stuff
do you
if i'm i'm asking you honestly and i ask
you i want you to answer me honestly um
do you struggle with addiction in any
way
no no no no totally clean okay all right
so this is purely
you're just not disciplined with your
money
yeah okay i'll go out and i'll buy like
a
air purifier or
some kind of appliance or i'll go out
and
just random stuff okay
and and when you're doing that anthony
is it because
it's exciting because you're bored
because like what's the what's the why
behind that impulse spending for you
i would feel like it's exciting because
every time i get money i'm just like oh
i have some money i can spend yeah and
then i'll just go out and i'll spend it
yep and then after you spend it when you
look back now where you're sitting
all the air purifiers and all the random
stuff you spent
has it has it been worth it is it worth
it
no not at all because then i end up
either never use it
it's just a paperweight at that point
i'll use it for about a week and then
that's it which is human nature by the
way everyone does that we all think if
we're going to spend money it is right
john talks about this how i do it too
how the chemicals in your brain it's
exciting your body you get a little
adrenaline and it's fun and you're like
okay okay so that happens to everyone
so for you anthony it's it's really this
moment of saying you know i'm gonna be
an adult
and there's a quote dave always says
that
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
so there's a level anthony that it's
like you gotta you you have to be a
grown-up you have to be an adult you
gotta pay your bills you gotta say no to
yourself even when you really really
want it
and so um on a very tactical side before
before this call gets short is i want
you to catch up on all of your bills
before anything else and so anthony i'm
gonna
really press you i want you
to get one or two extra jobs
today i want you today
like you you have to radically do
something different because if you keep
doing what you've been doing you're
gonna keep getting what you've been
getting and so bringing in an income and
then you're cutting everything and to
say you know i i will not i will not
spend on this but you talk about this to
the behavior change aspect though so
look dude put you got to put some
hurdles between you and this impulse
okay uh we rachel i talked about on a
previous show
it's the gap between stimulus and
response i'm gonna go buy this thing
i need this to i i need to go buy this
thing i need you just that that's the
gap you've got to control because that's
what's getting you in trouble what does
that mean take your debit card out of
your wallet and leave it at home
don't leave with it make your lunch and
take that to work to where that's all
you have and if you forget to take your
lunch you don't eat that day
you won't do that very many times before
you get really hungry and you start
making your lunch make peanut butter
jelly sandwiches or some beans and rice
or whatever it is to get to work make it
take get rid of amazon prime just just
delete it
make yourself have to jump through a
bunch of hoops
to go spend money
and that will give you some space on
your way to jumping through all these
hoops to say
what am i doing
what is my body trying to tell me what
am i trying to avoid what am i
embarrassed about what am i ashamed
about and my guess is you work real real
hard
and it's annoying to you
that you can't just go get what you want
is that fair
yeah no that's absolutely true you bust
your butt every day and you do work in
the heat and it's hot and it's hard
you're driving a forklift you've got a
skill that other people don't have
and dude i just want to thank air
purifier
and i can't afford it because they're
about to shut my gas off
and so the the not nice way of saying
this is you are broke and you're in a
scary position
you're about to lose your home dude
right
yeah yep so as rachel said it's time to
do everything differently right
opposite how old are you anthony anthony
i'm 32 32 okay
well i'm excited for you because i
really do hang on the line austin i'll
pick up we'll give you a subscription to
ramsey plus because that adds in every
dollar in the videos but anthony i want
you to be radical i want you to do the
opposite of everything you've been doing
i want you to work like crazy and i want
you to pay your bills instead of paying
for air purifiers change it up you can
do it you can do it
all right we'll be back for another hour
on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsay solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the ramsey headquarters here
in nashville tennessee this is the
ramsey show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your money and
your life and your work and your
relationships everything give us a shout
at
825-5225
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm john dalone joined here
by my good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls it's a free call
give us a buzz and let's go out to green
bay wisconsin and talk to lynn hey lynn
what's going on
hey um
i was calling because i needed some
thoughts and ideas um i am going to be
locked in a pretty intense custody
battle um that i didn't be coming
um what happened
i'm sorry
what happened
uh we went well i had my baby and
um he met her once
um for a couple of hours and then just
kind of disappeared and i didn't really
push things
um
back it back up so this is the father of
this baby we're all married
no we were not we were supposed to be
but i found out about a bunch of
infidelity and that was the end of it so
you had your baby and then the father of
that baby
saw her for just a few minutes and then
he took off and disappeared
for for a couple of hours the week that
she was born he um he met with her
um but he didn't see her after that he
did text for a while
asking general questions but
after a while he would um text
how is she doing and i would respond
she's good do you want to see her this
weekend and then he wouldn't respond and
we kind of rinsed and repeated that for
i want to say about four or five times
and then
um late october early november he just
stopped all contact um and i didn't
reach out because i didn't want to chase
him down and i had other things to worry
about sure you have a human being you're
keeping alive that's
right um
well uh
last one or the wednesday before last i
got served papers for a court hearing
and i work
i get my mail in the evening and i work
the weekends and so i wasn't able to
um look into an attorney or really
review the paper so i had made an
attempt to call him to see what he would
want for the proposed parenting plan
um and he didn't answer so when we went
into the well the court was over the
phone
um so
when i went there i had dropped off the
papers about 10 minutes before the
hearing because i was trying to get
everything to the court
on time
and i didn't have an attorney and um at
that point my
ex had said that he wanted full
placement and full custody under
allegations that i was horrifically
abusive and he feared for the life of
his child oh my gosh
i'm so sorry um
which put us in the position of having
to skip past mediation and go straight
to guardian and light up that's right
which is where the court assigns an
attorney to the kind of to the child
um
and so
take a second this is hard this is hard
um this is your baby how old is this
girl
she's 10 months 10 months wow
to this right this is uh
something that you didn't see coming
right
no i i didn't um
i thought because i had been amicable
and i had
offered for him to see her on weekends
that he would take me up on that if he
wanted um
and i've had people in my personal life
ask you know why why would he do this
what does he want i i the only answer
i've been able to give them is to um
to punish me because i i didn't
need him and i didn't call back to him
or
anything um
i'm gonna give you a piece of wisdom
moving forward okay
um there's a whole psychology about this
but i'll keep it real simple
stay out of his head
okay
why he's doing what he's doing is his
problem not yours
your energy and your focus is on
protecting this baby
and
making sure that um
things stay the way they are and by the
way while we're at it we need some child
support too
okay
why he's doing this
it doesn't matter yeah yeah what
this does he have an attorney
he does and i didn't know that until
until the day that i had called and
asked the court if there had been any
movement on the case
and that's when they let me know
but they said that he hadn't responded
to the paternity test and so they were
still awaiting papers before they could
put anything in motion
i mean at some point he's gonna have to
answer for the unpaid child support of
11 months and he's going to have to
answer for the text messages that you
have in writing
about how you reached out and tried to
offer support and he would never respond
he'll have to respond to the phone
records where you call him and he
doesn't answer
right so i don't know what his
attorney's trying to do but this isn't a
very winnable case
where where does he
um
i don't have the copy of the text
messages because my my phone ended up
with an error on june 3rd and everything
was deleted that i couldn't get to my
computer and the only thing i could get
to my computer was when i would plug it
in it would automatically ask if i
wanted to download any
pictures or videos
okay let's do this because i don't want
to get into the legal stuff like this
you need to talk to your an attorney
about that and um
the phone the phone company should have
the records that you need all that to
say is this um
i want you to get online and google
family um
court programs in your area
okay okay and there will be low-income
resources for people who need attorneys
for for family matters
okay okay if if they are unable to serve
you i want you to call a local the
nearest law school that you have and ask
for referral services either through
one of their in-house programs or one of
the externship programs or they will
have a list of people who take on cases
like this either pro bono or on a
sliding scale
because there's a group of attorneys and
um in another state i'm friends with
some of them who love
taking these kind of cases
because it's right
and it's the right thing to do okay but
we're looking for family court programs
or family law service programs
and even if you call a family lawyer in
town and say hey i don't have any money
this got sprung on me all of a sudden
this guy's coming out of the woodwork
after a year trying to claim things that
just bananas they may not be able to
take your services but they'll have some
refer
some referrals for you to call
for somebody to walk alongside you
in a way that you can afford it or it'll
be a free referral service
i'm so so sorry that you're going
through this and this has come out of
the left field on you um
again stay at his head
stay out of all the drama don't be a
part of the drama be a part of getting
the legal counsel that you need and
somebody to protect you and take care of
you and that baby through this process
so we can retain custody and move on
with our lives and by the way that dude
needs to pay a year's worth of child
support and make a plan moving forward
because there's 17 more years in that
baby's life
so so sorry that you're dealing with
this what a heartbreak what a heartbreak
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from laura in
texas
my husband and i are on baby step 2 with
forty five thousand dollars left to pay
off our combined income is around is
around a hundred thousand
i just started working at a side gig
delivering groceries three nights a week
after our son goes to sleep at this pace
we'll be debt free by next february we
live in a good area and i rarely go to
the sketchy parts of town but my mom is
but my mom
worries
about my safety and i don't think she
approves of me working so much i make 55
to 90 dollars a night
should i find another side hustle
oh laura this gets all of them laura
go john go
the wrong way john is ready to jump in
your mom doesn't get a vote
i don't care what your mom says unless
she wants to write you a forty five
thousand dollar check unless she wants
to pay you
ninety dollars she doesn't get a vote on
approving how much you work
good grief and what part of town golly
number two that's a that's a trigger for
me when someone says oh that's a sketchy
part of town that usually means
people look different than me or the
houses are smaller or the cars aren't as
nice
those people need groceries too if
you're in an unsafe part of town usually
people use the words unsafe
if you are scared to get hurt or injured
or killed that's one thing
but just because that part of town is
sketch it looks differently than you
dude go deliver in fact deliver more you
should be making more than 90 bucks a
night um i this just drives me crazy
you're married
you're married you have a child your mom
doesn't get a vote move on right
100
oh man you know that's a
it's a way it
drives me crazy
the the but seriously though laura and
anyone out there listening there is a
freedom when you're an adult
your parents do not get to say actually
dave and i thought about this on a
segment a few shows ago
because a girl called in and she was
like yeah my parents want me to invest
instead of pay off debt or whatever it
was
and dave's like just tell you know
scroll you don't know what you wanted
all of this they kept i wanna sit down
have a conversation explain why i'm
doing it he's like you don't owe them
anything you know this whole thing
so there's like this balance in life
when you're an adult and your parents
are still living and you have a
relationship which obviously laura talks
to her mom quite a bit because she knows
where she listens to her mom quite a bit
yes and she listens to her mom
of this balance and these boundaries
as an adult to go be an adult but what
is it that keeps people
tethered
to their mom's opinion or
dad's opinion it's a hundred different
things but usually it's
approval
i want my mom to think i'm doing a good
job okay and that usually comes from a
legacy of moms withholding
or controlling love based on performance
okay right
i will give you the nod i'll give you my
blessing when you're doing right and if
you're not and it leaves a kid always
fishing for i need that approval because
kids need that unconditional love but
when it's dependent on math grades or
basketball performance or in this case
what parts of town i enter or don't
enter right then you get chase it and
you'll chase it for the rest of your
life and it's when you can unhook from
that and say
i'm loved because this guy told me he's
all in
and i'm loved because i got a little son
who can't wait to see me when he wakes
up in the morning and i'm gonna work
bananas to give my house peace right
when you can unhook and plug into that
and not plug into this person who's like
well i don't know honey it's really
sketchy over there
there's 1994 model cars over there
and the lexus don't go over it
ah it gets me so far it gets me so
riled up man
um
those people need groceries too get over
there and help out
for sure it's not that sketchy if
they're paying to get groceries
delivered either they're doing fine in
the sketchy part of town and underneath
i just tried i hate that phrase i don't
think she approves of me working i don't
care i don't care yeah i don't care now
my mom still to this day she'll say
um have you been traveling i'll say yeah
i was in vegas here i went to florida
for a week and then we were back in here
and she'll say
no john that's you need some rest you
need to go that's a mom's job right
right but it's not about her approval of
me that's just her doing her mom thing
which i love and i say cool mom thanks
mom that's right that's right and uh i i
i yeah it's not attached to the strange
email that's my mortgage company they're
like that's cute but we still need our
payments right so i still am going to
work right um but she's doing her mom
thing but it's not an approval thing i
just don't like it yeah yeah i don't
like it i hear it here's the thing laura
i feel this way i feel like you are
quietly looking you have started this
process of working three nights a week
after your kids in bed and it's
exhausting
and you're gonna start looking for a
couple of little reasons to make into
big reasons so you can stop doing this
and slow down paying it off don't just
hit the gas or find another job that
will get you there faster
but get this thing done get it knocked
out and for god's sake unhook from your
mom's approval uh you don't need it all
right hey we got these new questions for
humans yes we have all different decks
right and it's one of the top selling
things in the company right now which is
still just super funny to me all right
but we've got we got girls night out
guys night out we got all kind this is
the workplace deck
because we should we should have done
girls night john we should we should
have oh my gosh are you ready i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna just throw i'm gonna
go all right let's do it okay what part
of the united states would you never
want to live
but i never want to live
i like it pretty much anywhere
i got mine what is it
i'm doing it why is oklahoma slightly
because you're sitting here but but part
of it's true because i have no reason to
be there texas you don't want to live in
texas because everyone's obsessed with
texas when they live in texas and i just
think it's a little bit like
really is it that great such a
contrarian i'm sorry but everyone's like
texas
i don't know
i love dallas i love san antonio i love
i mean there's some great cities in
texas but just the idea to say i live in
texas
i don't know california would be a tough
one for me to live in too too
oh that's probably so beautiful it's so
stunning and it's so beautiful san diego
yeah and malibu and
uh i'll all of it i just think it's
beautiful napa all the things okay um
let's see let's see let's see the clc
there was
um what's more disgusting
your car your desk or your bathroom at
home okay here's the thing we need to
talk about somebody cleaned up my desk
here at work yep they organized it all
straightened things out because i
couldn't stand looking at it john
because it's a wreck it's a wreck so i
took everything out and now there's just
a yellow pad it looks like it looks like
an office in a prison
but so it used to be my dad it's
probably my car my bathroom is is pretty
spotless um because that's disgusting
but i'm messy i'm not gross you know
what i mean yeah no no that's that's me
too i'm not an organized person my
closet's the worst i just it's
everywhere somebody i'm cleaning up my
day
i'll say car not my new car but my the
minivan
oh my truck's embarrassing oh it's bad
um what's the worst career advice you've
ever received
uh you should join ramsey i'm just
kidding um the worst career advice
uh can i tell you what it is yes well
i've got one what's yours fake it till
you make it
why is that the worst it's kind of like
that's terrible why because if you go in
and you're like yeah i can do that yeah
i can do that then you're in a position
where people are pissed because you're
questioning your job and you're like no
i think i can figure it out and you
can't you can't because you don't know
what you're doing because you faked it
so a part of me is like just own it yeah
yeah like if you're gonna i don't know
party's like yeah i'm really good at
this
i struggle with that but i'm awesome at
all i'm awesome at all of this i'm
hospital
i don't like fake it to make it i don't
know what the worst career advice here's
the worst career advice i've ever
received um
don't
don't look to move don't look too
[Music]
be grateful for your job
and so like if you're an assistant
director
naturally after x number of years and
you put in your and you've put in you've
learned that skill set and you have
exceeded that position
you start looking for associate director
jobs whatever and it's the advice i
received was like no stay put you're
good yeah and that wasn't good advice
okay last one okay
what's an office buzzword that drives
you nuts
what's an office i've got mine what is
it zoom zoom
something's going well like it went zoom
zoom and i'm like
[Laughter]
uh
you know what i can't there's a lot
i have a lot of office
buzzwords oh put the ball in the hoop
all
of the office buzzwords drive me crazy i
just hate office lingo you guys pick one
at ramsey
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
delaney joined here by my good friend
rachel cruz and we're taking your calls
on money and
life let's go to dustin in evansville
indiana hey dustin what's going on man
hello can you hear me i can can you hear
us all right
yes i can excellent so what's up brother
um i've been recently having
car problems um to a point where
the car isn't drivable
and um we recently took it to
the ford dealership for them to look at
it and they said it was a um something
called a transmission control module and
um
the uh the part is under a recall so
it's we don't have to pay anything for
it
um but they said that the the part is uh
on a back order
and uh it's to a point where they people
have been waiting months for this part
and um they recently said that some of
the people have been trading the car to
them because they've been waiting so
long
i'm looking to see i guess what is my
best option um i guess my
other option was to um
to buy like a backup vehicle
um or just
wait it out and
just use our other vehicle and my wife
drive me around to work yeah have you
gotten a second opinion
um i have not um i would be curious in
that the only reason i say that that's
it is because we had an air thing that
went out in our minivan and we took it
to honda and
went my husband took an uber to her home
from the dealership and he was like oh
you took it to the to the steelers ship
did ya
i was like that's a funny funny way to
put it but i do wonder like if there's
like a
you know a mechanic
who's not attached to a dealership if
wait what kind of
options he has
i absolutely would do that what are you
doing for transportation right now man
um my wife's just been driving me to
work every day i work kind of like a
hybrid where some days i'll go in and
some days i'll just work from home
since this is a recall is there any sort
of uh rental reimbursement or something
since they've admitted that your car is
not drivable because of our fault
um well
most of the the dealership that i went
to told us that there was no rental that
they would that would be available
and um i've kind of been doing my
research online too
to see like what other people have
that have had the same problem
and they've all kind of had that same
answer and they've kind of just been
waiting months for this part to come in
how much is the car once it's fixed how
much will it be worth
um it's probably around
i would say six thousand to eight
thousand okay
um are they will is the dealership
willing to give you that on a trade
i haven't asked about the trade yet um
that's kind of i was just gonna wait a
little a little bit longer and see
i'm rachel i would i would absolutely
here's um again i don't wanna throw any
dealership under the bus but i always
look at who's gonna make money off this
deal right
and i know a dealership makes money when
they do a transaction
and i know a dealership makes money when
they fix a car
right and so if
there's a way that they can encourage a
transaction
and encourage you to potentially take on
a car payment and we'll give you 4 000
for it right now go ahead and get you
another car it may be months and months
we don't know when you're going to be
driving
i'm not saying that they're unethical or
they're trying to steal from you i'm
just saying that the incentive is there
a
mechanic who's just running a mechanic
shop has one incentive that's to fix
your car so you'll pay them
right and so i would go check that out
first and see i wouldn't even tell them
about your experience at the dealership
yet i would take my car there and
um say hey here's or have it towed there
and it's worth 120 bucks to figure it
out before you go do something worth
thousands and thousands of bucks
and i'd go get a second opinion and once
it's fixed dustin is it the kind of car
that you've had issues with and you're
like i kind of want to upgrade like are
you ready for like is that the next step
or once it's fixed you're like oh no i
can drive for another year or two
um well it's only got 80 000 miles on it
so i'm sure it's got plenty of lifestyle
yeah yeah i would i mean since the
repair is free at the dealership
and going getting a second opinion um
i would just i would wait it out if you
could even though it's super annoying
um
you know with having one car but people
do that all the time um so it's doable
considering that the repair is gonna be
free i'd also call the dealership man
and see if you can get some sort of
credit even like a credit to yeah
for something i don't know and i'm not
saying all dealerships are stealing
that's what you said that's cool i
didn't mean to say that all over america
it was just a funny joke it is
i thought it was threatening people from
the uber driver that's so funny that's
so funny all right let's go to chris in
cookeville hey chris what's going on
hey how are you i have a question about
potentially selling a business and kind
of the
the what your thoughts are on that with
we have two mortgages one for rental
property one for our primary home
and other than that we don't have any
other debt but those are obviously
sizable debts and
the
couple options for selling the business
one would be
in one scenario we could potentially pay
off both houses
quickly at the closing
another scenario
one of the houses
we like the second scenario better
because of who
the people
and i know you guys are
all for
small businesses
so
i guess just kind of wondering what your
thoughts are on all of that do you want
to be out of this business
we kind of do my wife and i yes what
does kinda mean
well we're fatigued from it and we
we are um we're kind of ready to be done
with it yes what is kind of mean yeah
are you in or out you say dude we want
to sell this business or does she want
to sell it you want to keep it or vice
versa like or no we're done
i i'd say
pretty much leaning towards no we're
done
kind of pretty much are you in or out
i'd say out
are you do you feel good about that
yes yeah you know
i guess that's the really the purpose of
the question is i there are times i'm on
the fence because you know i love the
income from the business and the
potential of where it could go
what do you want to do after you sell
do you have a well
we have some projects we'd like to work
on and we would also stay on for a time
or i would i say we might want to take a
picture you would take a paycheck for a
season
yeah well you figured out what came next
i don't know if you want to quit the
business and they're going to keep you
on and pay your bills and you're going
to be debt-free and have a free rental
home i'd sell it
i don't know i don't know what the
concern is here's here's the deal just
because you miss it doesn't mean it's
right
you know what i mean
it's natural to miss it when you
transition out of that that's okay you
can date somebody for a long time and
you break up and it's painful even
though the breakup was the right thing
to do
and you miss them and you miss laughing
and you pick up your phone to call them
but you know that long term that was the
right thing to do it could be very
similar here the real question is less
about what we could do with this money
like do you want to be in this business
or not man
yeah yeah and that's i guess the only
reason it's not 100 knows because
well there's just always that doubt
but
i think my wife would be much happier if
i was not and
chances are my kids would be yeah
wait and i think did you start the
business chris from the ground up
yes yeah so you're the first generation
you know business owner and you guys
naturally always are gonna have it yeah
you're gonna have an emotional tie to it
uh but if you kind of run its course and
you see other things out there in life
that you're like that other things get
you excited and you've built this thing
and you can sell it you can do some
great stuff with the money and then you
can continue to live a great life and do
other great stuff then that's awesome
but if you love the business and you
want to be in it you and your wife still
are good with it
um
you can totally stay in it so you can
also keep the business and sell the
rental house that you can't afford and
hire somebody to provide you some relief
so you can spend more time with your
wife and kids so you don't have to
box yourself into an either or corner
here right
yeah
and so in the two scenarios of for
selling the one where we could
pay off yeah so the second one is it's
the people you like that so you have two
offers basically
yeah and you and you and you like the
second people better is that right is
you just you know them or you just feel
better about that but is it a worse off
how much of a loss will you take if you
did that versus the first
well the thing is it's almost an equal
amount but it's structured differently
okay so
just different amount of closing
and
[Music]
so the first one has a less favorable
structure but more closing
okay
yeah i mean if you just want to get out
cash out obviously that's when you just
take the money and go but if it's
someone that you love and you're and
they're gonna be your boss for a three
or four years
that might be the better end of the
deals that looking at the actual person
but i guess it's what you guys and the
ultimate the end game is for you is it
the money or is it what's your life's
going to be like in the next and you got
to make a call brother and to be a piece
make a call
[Music]
[Music]
psalms 4
8 in peace i will lie down and sleep for
you alone lord make me dwell in safety
harry kemp says the poor man is not he
who is without a scent
but he who is without a dream
harry kemp
all right let's go to kevin in tampa
florida what's up kevin how are we doing
good how are you guys thank you for
taking my call you got it what's up
hey so
um i just got engaged to my girlfriend
or fiance now and uh congratulations
thank you so much uh we're just trying
to figure out how to prioritize uh
saving up for the wedding and um
as well as paying our debts
she has ten thousand total just in
student loans and i have
uh 29 and um 9 000 in credit cards which
i plan to pay off by the end of this
year
and the rest of that in student loans
okay so what's your question
uh oh my question is um should i since
i'm planning to um pay off the credit
card um and
what what are your thoughts on kind of
like putting a pause on my student loans
while i save up for the wedding um
we plan to have the wedding in 2024
so pretty off our days out
yeah
uh
i mean i would my answer may change now
i thought you guys would you know be
getting married summer of 23 or
something i was like why are you waiting
so long um just because we wanted to uh
get our finances uh right no no kevin
just get married yeah go to the jp today
go congratulations brother you don't
need your friend you're fine you guys
you're doing it you're and you you're
gonna you're gonna do it so much faster
and more motivated together
when when you're married and you guys
are yeah you don't don't feel like
you're taking your finances or not
before you're getting married or even
having a baby you're good so
so i should save up for the weight or we
should save up for the wedding now
uh yeah i would do both i would
simultaneously continue to pay off your
debts but i'm okay with you putting some
cash aside yes for the wedding i don't
want you doing that for two years though
kevin so
i want you guys getting married i want
y'all y'all are broke you don't need a
hundred thousand dollar wedding that
you're paying for yourselves how much
you guys make how much do i make a year
um i make 65 and she ranges uh right now
she's a travel nurse but she's planning
on just getting a staff job uh early
next year okay
so right now she's probably making like
150 uh probably
able to save up 20 000 by the end of
this year and then she's going to go to
staffing which is probably like around
80 000. okay awesome so yeah i would i
would encourage you guys get married
sooner
way sooner way sooner uh i would
continue to work on your debt and your
debt alone to paying off your credit
cards let her be working towards her 10
000 in student loans and then you guys
have a total and say hey by
this date we would love to have this
amount of money so we can start planning
a wedding so that could be christmas of
this year whatever it is and so it may
not be it's not going to be a
huge wonderful
thing with flowers everywhere still
gonna be wonderful it's gonna be
wonderful but it yes it's gonna be
tempered because you guys are paying for
it and that's great that's great um
people spend so much money on weddings
and i'm not mad at that but man we spend
more effort and energy on that versus
the marriage so i'd rather get you guys
married and have a decent wonderful
beautiful wedding um
that you're that you're paying for and
then you guys together at that point
tackling the rest of this debt together
sounds good thank you so much guys you
got it and uh rachel i i've not heard
i'm sure they exist you may have some
friends i've not heard one person not
one
who
went ahead and did a super low-fi
low-key wedding during the coveted years
and with the intention of we're gonna go
ahead and get married now and we're
gonna throw a big party down the road
yes yes and i heard one person say i
wish i could take that back no not one
and then what's funny too is a lot of
them don't even go back and do the big
wedding because we're married like we're
married we're old and annoying we have
money and we want to go travel i want to
be with your family anyway so
we won yeah i've not heard one person
say you know what i wish we'd spend a
hundred thousand dollars and blown it
out for these photos
oh my gosh no we had winston had one of
his best friends was getting married may
of 2020. it was a destination wedding so
we were all we had everything booked you
know we were going winston was in the
wedding the whole thing and of course
you know yeah
and so uh we got a text from him and he
was like hey tonight get on zoom at 6
p.m
so we get on zoom at 6 p.m and there's
literally 200 people in the zoo and it's
just them two in the backyard both
parents and then like a pastor and they
just did it and now they're and now
they're killing they have a baby now
their life's great oh they're just
moving on and so there is weddings are
wonderful i don't want to be the one
those people are like you never need a
wedding no weddings are fun and they're
beautiful and they're exciting and you
celebrate something beautiful in life
i'm all for it but they are so they can
be so overrated yeah they can be so
overrated ugh
so
kevin get married kevin get married
yeah wait till 20 go now
kevin get married this weekend this
weekend and send us the photos if you
send us the photos we'll both put them
up
yes kevin if you get married this
weekend both rachel and i will post a
photo we'll even do something else we'll
se i don't know
yes we'll send you some gifts we'll blow
this up kevin have premarital counseling
first
do the response that's enough for rachel
let's go to debbie in jacksonville
what's up debbie
hi john hi rachel thanks for taking my
call of course what's up my husband
my husband and i um we're in our mid-50s
we have our primary mortgage and we have
a home that we're currently using as a
rental that mortgage otherwise we're
debt-free
i am not sure where to focus our extra
funds on the primary mortgage or on the
rental one caveat of the rental property
is that eventually we'd like that to
become our primary it's in a retirement
community that we love we're just not
ready to go there yet
our primary mortgage is we have about
320 left on it the home is valued at
about 550. our rental property we owe
about 210 and its value is about 320.
um
when are you going to retire
probably 10 years
i'd focus on your primary first
no the rental
okay debbie i'd sell the rental i know
you don't want me to say that even
though that's where they're gonna but
it's gonna be 10 years in a decade it's
fair fair for fair good job john i would
sell the rental and then you would owe
110 000 and you would knock that out in
a few years and then you could start
sucking away cash
but the difference between now and 10
years if you'd met the 10 year ago john
deloney that dude was a train wreck and
you and i i'm not super got it all
together right now but you should have
met that dude i'd do his nuts right
like who knows what the world's gonna
look like in 10 years
um i would not be paying
10 years worth of mortgage interest on a
half a million dollars for a decade i
wouldn't do it but that's me if y'all if
y'all just have to have to have to hang
on to it then it ends up becoming a debt
right
well yeah and and in 10 years debbie
think about if yeah you do all this you
pay it off how much cash you guys are
going to have freed up from your
mortgage once you pay off your primary
mortgage and investing all of it and
then what's your house currently will be
worth your primary and in 10 years all
of that together you guys could get
something awesome and maybe a better
location a better community who knows
what this community is going to look
like in 10 years or be i mean yeah
there's so much if you have kids gonna
have twins and say mom well you can live
by who knows what's gonna happen in 10
years right
um that's just that's just my thought on
it that's a long if you're telling me
two years yeah three years or something
then that's a totally different
proposition there
sure sure all right well thanks for your
advice absolutely so hey hello real
quick hang up how does that sound you
don't like that do you i know you don't
but tell me how that feels i know
no no it feels okay i
i've heard
dave talk previously about you know he
doesn't really like rentals unless you
can pay cash and he usually gives the
advice of selling the rental and so
i in my heart
knew that that was the right answer
but
i was just wondering if given the caveat
that you know we were hoping to end up
there if that shed a different light on
the situation
it did for me for about point five
seconds but then i gave you terrible one
almost you almost got rachel i was like
wait wait wait wait no no
yeah sorry debbie that's it you know in
your heart though and you know what it's
gonna feel so good it's gonna feel so
good when you throw that at your primary
mortgage
yeah because right now i mean you're
looking at being done right well
actually she said it's it's worth 300
right so or 350. so
but i mean like still 130 so looks at it
like
yeah
i'd much rather do that for sure and in
10 years you never know what's gonna
happen so all right hey rachel thank you
yes for hanging out today's show great
show john i want to thank austin kelly
james ben zach andrew will kelly's not
even here i think you will it's good to
see you showing up here at the last
minute thank everybody thank you america
for joining us um listen take care of
each other be kind out there and we will
see you soon
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you